wir sind in die schweiz gefahren um
einen 1000 euro tel mitten in den bergen
zu testen was das kann ob sich das lohnt
und für wen sich das lohnt erfahrt ihr
im video
die schweiz super teuer stolzer geld ist
wunderschön bekannt für seine qualität
und unglaublich schöne natur ich bin in
den bergen all diese punkte soll das
whiteboard hotel im französischen teil
der schweiz als übernachtungsmöglichkeit
verein aber was macht dieses hotel
besonders und ist es gerechtfertigt das
mit abstand teuerste hotel das wir
jemals auf diesem kanal getestet haben
das finden wir gemeinsam heraus ich
wünsche euch viel spaß der weg hierhin
war schon mal das erste erlebnis wir
sind nicht nur 800 kilometer gefahren um
dieses hotel zu testen sondern müssten
auch noch 15 minuten heyken deswegen
sehe ich auch so aus
wir wurden nicht hochgefahren was mich
schon mal gewundert hat für 1000 euro
noch nicht reingeguckt und gehen jetzt
mit euch das erste mal ins hotel
das ganze heißt eco luxury whiteboard
und diese kabine die wir haben ist die
teuerste und luxuriöseste die gegend von
apg mit design würde liebe grüße an
justin das ist keine ahnung warum aber
die wurde von einem apg irgendwie mit
gesponsert heißt timeless es gibt keinen
schlüssel das war das erste was mich
schon mal gewundert hat und das ganze
ist so zeltner wir dürfen keine schuhe
hier drin an haben deswegen gibt die so
ein eingangsbereich werden wir in so
schlappen reinschlüpfen es gibt
allerdings nicht nur hier drin was zu
sehen sondern wir haben wir jetzt das
luxuriöseste es hier draußen auch noch
ein paar sachen die wir für unsere
stimmen sind worauf er eingehen nachdem
wir uns das zimmer angeschaut habe
es wird romantisch
es werde licht das gesamte ding ist eine
kuppel vorne ist durchsichtig und wenn
das licht aus ist gehen wir natürlich
rausschauen wir sind 1500 meter überm
teil würde ich sagen also wir gucken uns
hier wirklich ins tal rein und was es
hier so zu entdecken gibt das wissen wir
jetzt selber mal herausfinden
wir haben einen ofen den über ein tablet
steuern können dass hier irgendwo rum
liegt direkt an der sollte direkt an der
seite hier können wir das wärme und
kälte machen und dann haben wir hier
direkt einen begrüßungsdrink wir haben
eine rettungskarte auf französisch auf
französisch das war hast dann richtig
lies ein buch über die diversesten oder
p g modelle der leute die 4000 euro
hotel buchen sind im zweifelsfall auch
an einer 50.000 euro oder natur
interessiert wir haben eine leere tüte
von ohne papiere wir haben streichhölzer
und fünf rollt cbd joints aber das ist
kein witz die konnte ich beim checkout
von der hotelbuchung dazu buchen und ich
fand das witzig deswegen habe ich
gemacht
also ist vollkommen legal aber ich
dachte das lassen wir nicht nehmen und
hab das einfach für 80 euro einen check
untersucht weil es hier so teuer ist
können wir die minibar komplett mit
benutzen wir haben berlin und
champagner
nichts besonderes wirtschaftlich aber in
letzter zeit kommen hielt sich im kopf
ab damit die aussicht hier ins tal nicht
verbaut wird gibt es keinen großen
fernseher hier vorstellt aber jeder ruhm
kommt mit einem ipad pro internetzugang
netflix account und damit sollte
eigentlich jeder gut bedient sein okay
cool wir haben mit dem zimmer aber wir
müssen auch aus dem ausland auf alle
unsere lieblings serien zugreifen können
deswegen wird dieses video
freundlicherweise von jpm mit neun vpn
habt ihr die möglichkeit mit einem klick
ihren standort zu einem der 5200 server
in über 60 ländern das hilft euch nicht
nur dabei eure lieblings serien von
überall auf der welt zuschauen sondern
auch streaming anbieter zu einem
günstigeren preis es wird einfach eure
location und kurzzeit den preis von dort
und spart geld und keine angst dank
notebooks müsst ihr euch keine gedanken
darüber machen dass euer internet
langsam leer ist und bleibt quasi genau
so schnell wie es ist und ihr könnt das
pokern von videos und so weiter
vermeiden und auch abseits eben
genannten punkte ist es super smartphone
zu nutzen einfach um seine eigenen daten
im internet zu schützen und sich weniger
angreifbar für marriott zu machen klingt
jetzt auf den ersten blick in der video
beschreibung auf
www.nordphoto.de vpn um einen
zweijahresplan inklusive eines
kostenlosen monat mit 73 prozent des
konsums kommen das an sich ist schon aus
aber es ist wie bei dir eine 30 tage
geld zurück garantie von jpm bekommt
also klickt auf den link könnt euch nord
vbn und ich danke dass sie mich und das
gesamte projekt unterstützen jetzt viel
spaß weiter mit dem
thema soll das
eco luxury
bekommt eine völlig neue bedeutung weil
es hier tatsächlich glaube ich mehr um
wellbeing und yourself mäßige sachen
geht als ich es mir vorher vorgestellt
habe der mir eine erklärung vom bett
best practice in der evening in the dark
steps to follow turn on bereits in ruhm
wait for two seconds am tv hörde ding in
hell deeply in twilight exzellenten type
color light also ich hatte es mir vorher
durchlesen können aber eine kleine
erklärung von jemandem hier der arbeit
der vielleicht auch nicht ganz schlecht
gewesen gutes zwischenfazit wir sind
fünf minuten drin und ich muss sagen ich
finde ich habe mir unter einem 1000 euro
eco luxury wakeboard hotel bisschen was
anderes vorgestellt bisher kickt mich
noch nicht so richtig wir machen weiter
hier haben wir die minibar jeder mit
ihrem atelier einfluss ein buch über
alle uhren kaffeemaschine wasserkocher
tag und eine hoffentlich gut gefüllten
minibar denn die ganzen sachen cola
süssgetränke wasser reiswein wie
apfelsaft und nichts im eisfach
standardausstattung würde ich sagen und
bestimmt auch hochwertiger wein und
hochwertiges bier aber auch da
wo sind die 1000 euro hinter schenke sie
sind sehr gut und einen safe vielleicht
ganz nützlich weil man das ganze ding ja
nicht abschließen kann märz weiter zum
bad ich gehe davon aus dass das
tatsächlich erste sagen
das wird
[Musik]
wir haben hier also betreuung mäßig
verputzt sieht super stehen auch super
neu komplett unbenutzt fast und jetzt
kommt das highlight wir haben nicht nur
eine private sauna in unserem hotel
sondern auch einen eigenen whirlpool der
sich aber draußen befindet das werden
wir gleich alles mal testen und ein
bisschen genauer unter die lupe nehmen
genauso wie die sauberkeit vom zimmer
und vom bad jetzt heißt es erstmal ins
hauseigene restaurant und ein
drei-gänge-menü genießt
[Musik]
ich glaube essen und regionales essen
können die schweizer halten die produkte
alle von hier sind und den guten koch
haben wird es ein absolutes fest es
empfiehlt sich an wie so einen mix aus
rustikalem skihütte aber auch luxury
nichts ausrichten
[Musik]
bevor wir mit dieser taschenlampe das
badezimmer unter die lupe nehmen schauen
wir uns erstmal die allgemeine
sauberkeit des zimmers an und ich habe
hier schon etwas entdeckt kleine sachen
die das die glühbirne hier mit
irgendwelchen ligen fingern trendig
haupt wurde und die komplett versifft
aussieht hinter der lampe
staubig ich besonders viel aber es ist
staub da die kugel an sich schon auch
nicht besonders clean also sind auf
jeden fall überall spuren da klar das
ist nichts was man jetzt nach jedem
besuch sauber macht aber man sieht auf
jeden fall irgendwelche spuren dies aber
ist der kühlschrank er sieht ziemlich
sauber aus niesky gläser die sind auch
komplett clean und jetzt zur
königsdisziplin bat um zimmer mit den
fahrern es keinen gefallen dass wir
nicht nur ein bad zu überprüfen haben
sondern auch eine sauna und das ist
wahrscheinlich noch viel schlimmer als
das badezimmer wir starten aber in der
küche denn ich habe gerade eben schon
mal einen blick darauf geworfen und
überall wo sich leute hier tee gemacht
haben und so sind flecken die einfach
nicht weg gemacht wurden weiter zum
beispiel diese ablage die komplette ich
komplett dreckig sieht aus als wenn ich
schon so komplett verkalkt in den
armaturen hier und da kleine flecken
aber zum duschen oha meine socken für
armaturen clean ablagefach auch klima
nicht kriegen komplett dreckig ansonsten
ist die dusche ziemlich fein
tritt die toilette und beleuchtet
das bad wurde von uns bis dato noch
nicht benutzt a
lässt die sonne an der toilette ist
schon einiges dreckig zu retten halb
sauber und wir jetzt die absolute
königsdisziplin die sache
mit der faust ins gesicht ist schädlich
presse stadt nicht ja da ist komplett
dreckig aber
komplett denkmal das sind nur sachen die
jetzt hier von dem stein herunter
gelaufen sind deswegen wollen wir da mal
nicht zugänglich sein viel interessanter
sind die sitzflächen
[Musik]
deutlich kleiner als gedacht ja ich
glaube das ist einfach so tief ins holz
eingegangene ekelhaft
verfärbung von allen leuten die vorher
hier waren ich glaube aber tatsächlich
dass man da nichts gegen machen kann
tatsächlich glaube ich dass das
eigentlich ziemlich normal ist dass es
eigentlich ziemlich gut ab und
zu guter letzt und zum großen finale
greifen wenn die minibar schlüpfen wir
in die bademäntel und springt in unseren
eigenen persönlichen uhr
[Musik]
das zimmer in sofort zu schlafen ist ja
an sich schon besonders aber zu merken
was für qualitäts materialien genutzt
wurden um das einzurichten macht das
wirklich wirklich besonders alles wir
sehr gut gewählt die materialien passen
gut zusammen und man fühlt sich einfach
wohl der ofen dazu ist noch das
sahnehäubchen auf der torte ich weiß
nicht ob man das so sagt aber es ist
wirklich wirklich cool das zimmer und
man merkt einfach dass gedanken daran
geflossen sind gewundert hat mich ein
bisschen dass kein schlüssel gibt gerade
weil man außerhalb von port ist also man
wird zwangsläufig das zimmer verlassen
und seine wertgegenstände dort lassen
und die passen nun mal nicht alle in
diesem fall so viele wertgegenstände
habe ich nicht aber mein laptop meine
kamera und der zweite laptop von leo
passen einfach nicht zusammen in den
kleinen zeigt außerdem hat mir für den
preis zu dem wir gleich noch kommen
irgendwie so ein bisschen der tools
gefehlt trotz alledem natürlich
unglaublich eine eigene sauna und den
eigenen whirlpool zu haben in dieser
kulisse ist das schon wirklich besonders
deswegen bekommt das zimmer von mir eine
4 5 von 5 sternen der halbe punktabzug
einfach nur weil das zimmer nicht so
richtig intuitiv zu verstehen war obwohl
das vielleicht eigentlich eher was für
den service ist der service hier kommen
wir zum ersten richtigen kritikpunkt als
wir angekommen sind mussten wir fast
eine dreiviertel stunde warten bis wir
bedient wurden weil sich um andere erste
gekümmert wurde und so weiter in anderen
sehr teuren hotels bin ich gewohnt aus
den letzten tests dass sich einfach mehr
leute um die ankömmlinge kümmern gerade
wenn es ein hotel ist bei dem es
vielleicht ein bisschen zu erklären gilt
was hier auch ein problem ist denn uns
wurde quasi gar nichts erklärt
niemand hat uns zum zimmer geführt
niemand hat uns die besonderheiten von
zimmer geführt und das haben wir dann
auch zu spüren bekommen dass wir selber
hoch laufen mussten hat mich auch
irgendwie ein bisschen gewundert klar
ist wir sind in der schweiz das wandern
ist da irgendwie großes thema und das
war jetzt auch kein riesenproblem für
uns aber es wurde nicht mal angeboten
dass wir uns hätten entscheiden können
ob wir hochgefahren werden oder laufen
müssen und im endeffekt war man schon so
eine viertel stunde unterwegs geradewegs
den berg hoch ich kann mir vorstellen
dass da bei dem preis nicht jeder punkt
rolle bekommt der service also von mir
zwei von fünf sternen verpflegung wir
haben nicht nur die aufnahmen vom essen
verloren sondern ich habe auch vergessen
dass zu moderieren naja ist auch nicht
so super wichtig denn das essen war so
ne 355 sauberkeit an sich eigentlich
ganz gut mit dem bloßen auge war relativ
wenig zu erkennen die zimmer waren
aufgeräumt es waren clean alles super im
whirlpool war frisches wasser der
kühlschrank war sauber auf den zweiten
blick allerdings hat man gemerkt hey die
glasfront vorne hätte sauberer sein
können das bad war nicht besonders
sauber gerade als wir die blaulicht
lampe an gemacht haben haben wir schon
einige stellen gefunden und dem geld
einfach nicht gerechtfertigt ich würde
eine 3,5 von 5 gegen die lage klar es
ist kein staat hotel wo man rausgeht und
mitten im leben ist aber genauso ist es
ja gedacht dieses portal funktioniert
nur genau in so einer kulisse deswegen
ganz klar ohne weiter drum herum zu
reden nur 55 meine schaut euch das noch
mal das ist einfach wunderschön und so
was erlebt man nicht in ein licht
verseuchten stadt in der stadt in der
viele google ist genau so muss es sein
der preis wir haben uns für den
teuersten pott entschieden weil ich das
beste testen wollte was hotel zu bieten
hat und wir haben für eine nacht über
1000 euro bezahlt die schweiz ist teuer
und wir haben uns für die opg variante
entschieden wir hatten einen eigenen
whirlpool wir hatten eine eigene sauna
aber über 1000 euro ist komplett darüber
wirklich völlig falsch angesetzt
scheinbar wir wissen ja wie viel sie
nehmen können denn scheinbar wird das
auch gebucht für mich aber völlig
unangemessen für diesen preis hätte uns
angeboten werden müssen dass wir hoch
gefahren wäre es hätte 24 stunden butler
service geben müssen es hätte so viele
kleine dinge mehr geben müssen als das
was im endeffekt war eine leinwand die
man runterfahren kann anstatt einem ipad
und so weiter ich kann nicht anders als
dem hotel hier die schlechteste
bewertung zu geben die wir haben null
von fünf sternen ich finde das thema
wäre eigentlich so in der 300 bis 350
euro richtung richtig angesiedelt so ein
bisschen in die richtung wo die anderen
potts auch hingehen wir haben jetzt aber
nochmal auf die website geguckt und die
sind da anscheinend anderer meinung denn
in der winterzeit kostet das ganze über
2000 franken wenn es leute gibt die das
dafür ausgeben wollen okay ich würde
euch dazu nicht raten und das hier ist
die finale bewertung ich hoffe mich hat
das video besser gefallen als meinem
portemonnaie das wir gerne leichter
vergesst nicht den kanal zu abonnieren
dann werden wir uns unserer tage
[Musik]